تحتفل وطوائف المسيحيه التي تتبعه تقويم
الغربيه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه اليوم بعيد
البلاد المجيد وتحمل احتفالات هذا العام
شعار روح ميلاد تجمعنا حيث تتركز فعاليات
الاحتفال في مدينه بيت لحم امام المحترفين
في ساحه كنيسه المهد والشوارع المحيطه بها
للمدينه
[موسيقى]
مباشره
هذا العام يحمي شعار روحوا بلاد تجمعوا
[موسيقى]
اذا طلع على مزيد حول التفاصيل الاجواء
السائده الان في مدينه بيت لحم في ضوء هذه
الاحتفالات ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره سمير
ابو شماله سمير الاجواء في بيت لحم
عبد الصمد
مدخل الشمالي لمدينه بيت لحم بيت لحم قبه
رحيل قبل نصف ساعه كان هناك توجه لعدد من
السيارات في موكب الاستقبال
البطريق بير باتيستالا وهويار كلاتين في
القدس حيث يصل خلال هذه خلال هذه الساعه
الى هذه البوابه التي خلف في مباشره وذلك
لدخوله الى مدينه بيت لحم
لتنظيم ايضا لاداء قداس منتصف الليل في
كنيسه المهد في مدينه بيت لحم
البطريرك هذه بوابه عفوا هي تفتح فقط لبره
واحده من قبل الجانب الاسرائيلي التي تفصل
مدينه القدس الى بيت لحم وتفتح مره واحده
فقط في العام وذلك بمناسبه هذه الاعياد
الخاصه الطوائف المسيحيه وفق التقويم
الغربي والشرق ولكن اليوم الطواف المسيحيه
وقف تقويم الغربي تحتفل في هذا اليوم بعيد
الميلاد المجيد حيث انطلق موكب غطه الباطن
يارك من باب الخليل في مدينه القدس
المحتله وتوجه الى كنيسه دير الياس
ومن ثم سيتم استقباله من قبل عدد من
الشخصيات والرؤساء البلديات في داخل
محافظه بيت لحم في داخل مدينه القدس ما
بعد ذلك سددته تحدي البوابه لدخوله همم
يتقدم هذا الموكب سيكون هناك الاف من
عناصر الفرق الكشفيه التي ستستقبل
الباتريرك الى داخل مدينه بيت لحم مع
المحتلين من سواء من الطوائف المسيحيه في
داخل الفلسطينيين في داخل الاراضي
الفلسطينيه او حتى من الحجيج الذين
توافدوا بمئات الالاف خلال هذا العام الى
مدينه بيت لحم بعد جاء حقيقه كورونا عندما
كان هناك تعطيل لهذه الحركه السياحيه في
داخل هذه المدينه التي تعتمد في اساسها
على السياحه هناك اجواء احتفاليه كبيره في
داخل باحات كنيسه المهد في داخل وسط مدينه
بيت لحم حيث هناك عدد من المئات العناصر
من الامن الفلسطيني قد انتشروا منذ صبيحه
هذا اليوم في شوارع المؤديه الى الكنيسه
وذلك لتنظيم دخول الباطنيه لبدء مراسم
الرسميه الذي سيكون في استقباله المحتفلين
بشكل مئات الفلسطينيين الذين يتوافدوا منذ
صبيحه هذا اليوم والاجانب والحجيج الى
داخل هذه الساحات وذلك الاستقبال الباطل
لتنظيم هذه فعاليات الرسميه سيكون هناك
ايضا في قداس منتصف هذا الليل سيكون هناك
ايضا
الشخصيات السياسيه وايضا المجتمعيه وهمم
الرجال الدين وايضا يتقدمهم في هذه
الشخصيات الرئيس الفلسطينيه محمود عباس
الذي متوقع ان يكون مشاركا في هذه في هذا
القداس منتصف هذا اليوم نحن الان نتوقف
امام الجدار الذي ايضا يجتمع على اكثر من
ثلاثه من مدينه بيت لح التي ايضا يقتطع
منها هذا الجدار الفاصل والذي يحاصر مدينه
بيت لحم ايضا ب 22 مستوطنه باقتطاع المزيد
من الاراضي الفلسطينيه وهذا ربما يزيد من
معانات هذه المحافظه جراه هذه الاجراءات
الايصاليه ولكن اليوم احتفال داخل المدينه
بمناسبه عيد الميلاد المجيد يعقوب
المسيحيه التي تسير على التقويم الغربي